allied so allied is director by Robert
Zemeckis and stars Brad Pitt and Marion
Cotillard they are spies in World War
two and they are doing one thing and one
thing only
kaylynn Nazis they play the part of
husband and wife and then they fall in
love and become husband and wife and
then Brad Pitt's government folks are
like hey by the way your wife is a
German spy if she's not a spy hey no
harm no foul sorry for the inconvenience
if she is you're gonna kill her and
prove your loyalty to us and now Brad
Pitt has to investigate on his own and
find out if his wife is indeed a spy in
pitching this movie for what it actually
is that holes your wife's a spy oh is
she isn't she think that's actually the
second half of the entire movie the
first half is them falling in love
that's what this movie is the trailer
pitch this movie like it's some super
spy thriller or something but really
this movie is a romance and you need to
know that I need to brace you for that
this movie first and foremost is a
romance the first half of this movie is
that meeting them falling in love yes
there are scenes of thriller esque spy
stuff in it and they are actually really
exciting and very well-executed if I
really had to categorize this one like
this a blockbuster was still around
where to put the VHS it would be in the
romance section it's a very romantic
movie and it's actually sweet to watch
these two build their romance which
makes it more impactful it's like a bomb
just dropped on this dude's lap was like
yeah that woman you love of your life
she's inspire for the Nazis it's
actually one of those elements where I
wouldn't want to know about that going
into this movie but the trailer has to
show it otherwise people wouldn't
actually go if it was a movie that was
just pitched like hey watch these to
fall in love it'd be boring as hell and
people wouldn't launch it but the pacing
to the road leading up to that this
movie had uneven as payson times I was
checking my watch there were times when
I was bored as I was watching the movie
I was like could they have shaved time
off they condensed a few things here and
there maybe we didn't need to see every
facet of the romance bloom and blossom
for half the movie and you could have
concentrated more on the thriller aspect
of it Brad Pitt does a fine job in this
movie he really does Marion Cotillard
this is a great job in this movie
because Marion Cotillard
is great in anything and everything
she's in and does he step for when she
dies in the Dark Knight Rises that does
scene itself nope everything else though
she's great but when Brad
it is going out there and he's trying to
find his wife's in his is it just
roadblock after roadblock and the
government's like hey don't do that he's
like I have to that was really great you
really are on a trail you want to prove
this woman's innocent in that I can't
say the movie faulted on the execution
of the second half or rather some of the
pacing in the first half and some of it
throughout but I love that this movie
did which a lot of movies about spies is
like oh that person's a spy oh no
they're not who we actually have to find
the truth but it does well is it gives
you enough on both sides to be like I
don't know what's real and that's just
great because you don't want to just
flat-out like oh this is clearly the
truth I like it when a movie keeps you
on your toes you know yours like is it
this it's enough information supporting
that or is it that doesn't have a matrix
parting that I don't know by the time
the ending wrapped and the way the
ending wrapped up I will say allied is a
good time no alcohol required undeniably
enjoyed it I just don't think I would go
back to see it in a world of so many
movies so much film out there I don't
see myself going here it's a Friday
night let's watch allied again alright
guys so allied have you seen it what did
you think about it what's your favorite
romance of all time whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more